I'm Melissa vikander and this is the
wired order complete interview I know
this now and that was my worst one
how does ELISA we can't pronounce her
name how I would say it would be Alicia
vikander does unless you can to have
Instagram I did have one I already
freaked out about a month in feeling
like I had to post things so no I don't
have an Instagram account anymore let's
here we can to eat it's probably one of
my biggest hobbies in life I don't eat
much red meat but apart from that I kind
of eat everything what language does
ELISA vikander speech I'm trying with my
English I thought my native language
it's Swedish I have a very good Swedish
tongue twister for you guys
coo coo coo coo common and try and say
that about 20 times in a row Hermann who
yeah you see it's it's a hard one I
speak some Danish nose care for sex
nightly dance khmer yeah so nobody look
nervous man David ooh exciting I thought
that was it it's more is Alyssa vikander
single no is Alyssa Vick and English no
I'm I'm not it kind of sounds like it
sometimes because I've lived there for
quite a few years and sometimes had a
bit of an English trying but no I'm
Swedish is a little canned nominated for
an Oscar not at the moment but I won at
one of those Oscars two years ago who is
a canvas love this mother I was on the
phone with her just now before I came
here I'm gonna let her know that that is
one of the most googled things my mum is
muddled yeah follow vikander
one of the coolest women on earth how
tall is Alyssa vikander I'm so pleased
that this question comes up waiting up
under your name is my height it says
that I'm in centimeters 166 and I'm
actually 167 and a half how to dress
like
Lokhande you wake up in the morning and
you put on something like mint green how
did ELISA vikander become famous that is
kind of a byproduct to the job that I do
how did Alice see we can meet Michael I
actually saw him on a dance floor he has
some very very impressive dance moves
oh we thought it was not any Michael it
was Michael Fassbender unless he became
a tomb raider training I did a lot of
animate training rock climbing swimming
a list of the kind of tomb raider earth
diet for me to gain about 10 12 pounds
that I did for this role that meant that
I had to eat all the time which made me
very happy
Elisabet canned stunts I did most of the
things myself and then of course you
have an incredible team with
professional stunt girls that I was
surrounded with who both trained me and
who also did a few things that are
considered being a bit dangerous that
I'm not allowed to do ELISA
we can oh versus Angelina Jolie that
would be a cool film I've only passed by
her in a room but I would love to
actually probably meet her and she also
made lara croft into an icon so for that
I'm I will always be thankful oh this is
about Lara Croft is Lara Croft rich you
would presume yes but I think you should
go and see because in our story it's
kind of different from the previous
films you'll get the answer to this if
you go and watch the film is Lara Croft
an archaeologist
once again this might be what she
aspires to be in the future we hope to
give you the Lara Croft that you so well
known but also with some new history is
Lara Croft a superhero no but she's
super cool is Lara Croft a psychopath
this is giving me a lot more inspiration
if I ever get to play this character
again is Lara Croft based on a real
person don't think so but if she is I
would love to meet her does Lara Croft
have a love interest I don't know one I
hope that she will find love in the
future does Laura Croft have tattoos
maybe some hidden ones does Laura Croft
ha
fake polygons and what's this Swedish
person asked for translation does Lara
Croft
die she's famous for falling over quite
a bit but the cool thing about her is
that she always stands up again